khloe kardashian is shutting down rumors
about her dating life specifically she
says she's not dating harry josie you
just have to
deal with it it all started earlier this
week when rumors swirled that the good
american founder is dating the two hut
to handle star you remember him the 24
year old australian who had an on and
off relationship with francesca they
even got engaged at one point do you
want to get married
harry knows i want to marry him so yes
of course
and we can't forget the time he said
this so i've hit everyone famous i've dm
like courtney kardashian kendall i hit
her with the hello my little butter
chicken so what sparked the speculation
with chloe this photo
harry driving a bentley with some lavish
floral arrangements in the front scene
the pick comes on the heels of a blind
item posted on a kardashian fan account
claiming that the two have been dm'ing
back and forth and get this the rumor
says harry allegedly picked up a bentley
and flowers just to deliver them to her
house it's just all
like weird what's happening well coco
caught wind of it she hit up the
comments section and wrote absolutely
not true it is what it is plus dating is
simply not on chloe's list of priorities
right now a source told et last month
that the reality star is focusing on
herself following the recent drama with
her ex tristan thompson the father of
her daughter true last month the nba pro
admitted that he fathered a child with
marilyn nichols and as a result he
issued a public apology to coco our
source says quote chloe isn't rushing to
get back into the dating world at this
time chloe has been spending time with
her sisters and family working out
eating healthy and focusing on her mind
body and soul she's getting back on her
a-game i think working on your personal
growth internally is something that will
be a forever mission and i always want
to evolve and grow and mature
emotionally because that's how we become
better people and the results are
showing
i love to work out and i love to just
like that's my selfish time check out
these before and after pics of coco's
gym progress chloe explains in the
caption that the picks were taken three
months apart gotta say we're super
impressed by her dedication and
discipline and on monday the reality
star showed off her ripped body in this
topless photo promoting her apparel
company good american we all want to be
cute over here okay and when khloe isn't
busy working on her bud she's working on
her new reality show the kardashians you
have no idea what's coming
are you ready the kardashians
yep that's another sneak peek at the
kardashian jenner's new hulu reality
series and with the new teaser fans can
expect its release sometime soon here's
what coco told ellen degeneres back in
october either end of january
early february fast really fast so
that's the beauty of hulu we're
streaming and we get to have a much
quicker turnaround than previously and
we're really excited they're here now in
the back shooting with us and
we're so happy to be you know up and
rolling again
[Music]